okay i love me some sony but this should
win an award for
narrowest target demographic of all time
[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and this is a
brand new smartphone from sony
it's called the sony xperia pro so a lot
of you guys may remember i pretty
recently did a video
on why people don't buy sony phones
where you know i gave their recent
phones a lot of credit and admired how
technically impressive they were but i
eventually landed basically on the
conclusion
that people don't buy these because
they're focused on enthusiast features
at the expense of the everyday normal
experience
which is not a recipe for selling a lot
of them so then they drop this new phone
and this phone this phone
takes that imbalance farther than any
phone
i've ever seen for all the good and all
the bad so just looking at this guy
you know the phone itself is pretty
understated it doesn't seem that special
right off the top
it's basically an xperia 1 mark ii again
which was a great phone but it's a year
old now so it's the same snapdragon 865
same internal specs same 4k display
same triple camera system on the back
but as you can kind of start to see it's
modified in a few key ways
and it costs two thousand
five hundred dollars 25 okay
okay hold on a second it's called the
pro
and you know we know that the pro phones
are the the highest end ones the best of
the best so
what's so special about this one right
hot take this phone
is the only real pro phone it's the only
phone that deserves the word pro
in the name okay so we have iphone 12
pro
cool huawei mate 40 pro nice oneplus 8
pro
but those phones are just using the word
pro to sell you
you know upscale everyday phones this
phone is an actual professional
tool so it starts with the design right
at the bottom of this phone you'll find
a literal hdmi port so that's a micro
hdmi plug
behind this flap alongside the usb type
c
so you don't see that very often so keep
this in mind and then instead of
straight glass and metal this phone is
coated in this black
polycarbonate jacket all the way around
on the sides on the back
even on the front and it's pretty nice
actually there's no camera bump
so the phone sits perfectly flat and
honestly you probably don't even really
need a case for this phone
it's kind of ruggedized that way you do
lose wireless charging for some reason
but
as you'll see pretty soon that's not a
huge concern
then last but not least this phone has
an array of
5g antennas you have four beamforming
antennas all the way around this phone
that no doubt take advantage of the
plastic jacket
instead of metal or glass that's way
better for reception
and all of that is packing to a body
just a little bit bigger than the
previous
xperia one mark ii so this phone is
designed to act
as a primary viewfinder for
a sony mirrorless camera or really any
camera with hdmi for that matter
so they've built custom software and
hardware into the phone to make it
happen so when you put it all together
it looks something like this
not super elegant but not too bad
just very technically impressive so the
phone connects to the camera
via that hdmi port there's a custom app
with an extra custom button on the side
of the phone to trigger it
and immediately you get the 4k hdmi feed
on the phone now a couple things about
this number one that's pretty sweet a
lot of creators out there have a
mirrorless camera already
and a smartphone so combining these two
to have a nicer display
makes a lot of sense but then number two
the special 5g workflow pieces built in
will let you do crazy things it'll let
you live stream with this 4k
full frame quality to sites like twitch
and youtube and with services like
streamyard streamlabs which is sick it's
the
awesome freeing feeling of not being
tied to your computer anymore and still
getting
live full-frame quality that's so cool
and if you're feeling adventurous
you can even add usb-c from the phone to
the camera too
and this phone's 4 000 milliamp hour
battery will act as a power bank for the
camera
extending its battery life and that also
enables ftp
transfer so if you're live blogging like
taking a bunch of high resolution photos
those photos go straight to the phone
and then can be sent
straight to the truck or straight online
from the 5g
of the phone itself so that's all sweet
and pretty unheard of but at the same
time
this is like i said a little bit
inelegant you do need a cage
to attach anything like this to the a7
s3 so i've used the a7s
and so now you have a hot shoe mount
that connects to the phone i happen to
use
a hot shoe microphone so i've had to put
the mount on the side
the weight distribution's a little bit
off but it's not horrible there's a lot
of screws and mounts involved to moving
things around to put it on the side
it took a few minutes to set up and get
just right but we got it done
but then once it's set up the hdmi
output renders the touchscreen
on the camera itself useless since it's
off
and it only outputs one at a time so
since there's no touch controls
transferred via hdmi
you do get menu control through the
buttons still and you can see all that
stuff but there's no touch to select
and you lose touch to focus for photos
and videos
the one thing you do get is the ability
to zoom in on the actual
literal hdmi feed and use it as a focus
assist but that's nowhere near as
powerful
as focus peaking or false color which
are built into
some more pro monitors and then it just
kind of feels off that the hdmi feed
doesn't even take up
the whole display on the phone like it's
it's a 21x9 display still
and unless they're shooting 21x9 video
it's just going to feel like there's a
lot of wasted space
that you can't use for other things so
this phone simultaneously became
the most comprehensive professional
durable pro tool i've ever seen as a
phone
and the most niche phone of all time so
that 2500
price seems wildly high
because when you look at it as a phone
with a few cool
tricks up its sleeve that is crazy high
most
phones are a thousand dollars at the
high end
twelve to fifteen hundred and if you do
something really crazy like fold in half
maybe you can justify being two grand so
that looks really expensive
but if you're a professional or a
creator or you're in this world already
and you've ever shopped for an external
monitor for your mirrorless camera
then you know how hard it is to find a
4k
oled viewfinder that's this thin
that has an all-day battery life that
can charge your camera
that has 5g built in and has custom
software for transcoding and uploading
huge video files and photos
straight to the internet so 2500 bucks
seems like a deal and that's really just
because
such a technical rarity really nothing
else does that
it's already just hard to find a good
oled viewfinder
most of those are in 4k most of those
have a battery life of about half an
hour tops and then none of those
have 5g built in so when you make
something that no one else makes
who's to say it's overpriced there is no
equivalent to compare it to i just
looked on small hd site one of their
nicest monitors
is this seven inch hdr on camera monitor
but
it's not 4k and it's not oled and it's
three thousand dollars
so this phone earns the pro name more
than any other phone out there
no doubt about that but the sad thing is
like as a professional myself even i am
not in
the extremely narrow target demographic
for
a setup like this like i would rather
take that small hd monitor
that's a little brighter and has that
little bit of a larger viewing area
and those professional tools like
waveforms and false color over
the 5g that this has so my theory my
take
is there's about 30 people in the target
demographic for this phone
and they all work in nfl stadiums as
those photographers down on the field
videographers
who need this whole setup and they're
sending live video and live photos right
up to the truck and to the broadcast
and they need that type of speed
immediately from their viewfinder
those people should get a sony xperia
pro but for pretty much
everyone else the screen isn't quite
bright or big enough
the app is a little bit too buggy the
compatibility is a little too rough
and this just probably isn't what you
need no matter what the price is and
even framing it
as a smartphone with extra cool features
probably won't help that this ultimately
falls perfectly
into the thesis of my original sony
video about why people don't buy their
phones which is that they make things
that are
really technically impressive and that
no one else is
actually doing in a lot of ways it's
just the target demographic is
so small that they're not gonna sell a
ton of these so i would say definitely
check out that video it'll be the first
link below like button if you want to
watch it
sheds a little more light on the more
specifics of the last gen of this phone
and there are parts shared in this one
uh but that explains
the whole theory in more detail too it's
just i don't know as a professional i
like seeing stuff
made for professionals but i just think
the packaging of it
as a smartphone is a little bit odd
either way
that's pretty much it for me thanks for
watching let me know what you think and
i'll catch you guys
in the next video peace
[Music]